[Música]
vivimos en un mundo en donde todo es
visible sin embargo yo les pregunto que
es azul
en el 2009 perdí la visión de un día
para otro
y lo que
sentí es que yo ya no me encontraba
en ese mundo visible
se han puesto a pensar qué pasa con las
personas que somos invisibles
las primeras palabras que escuché de mi
psicólogo que me atendió fue no te
preocupes no pasa nada
como no va a pasar nada no veo perdí la
visión y con ella más cosas amigos
trabajo familia
y me dice que no pasa nada
para usted no no pasa nada
porque no siente lo que yo siento
alicia quieres que te diga algo
yo soy ciego
eso no me impresionó
sí pero tienes una vida ya hecha y la
mía en este momento está de fecha
alicia
tú conociste el azul el verde el
amarillo el rojo yo no yo nací ciego y
yo te pregunto ahora que es azul
a mí me dicen que el cielo es azul que
el mar es azul que los árboles son
verdes que el pasto es verde
ahora dime que es azul
eso sí me impactó eso sí me dejó sin
palabras
como le explicaba
yo
que es azul
hasta el día de hoy yo no le puedo decir
algunos de ustedes lo saben
terminé mi rehabilitación y me fui a
otro centro
para seguir preparándome para la vida
ahí me dijeron que tenía que tomar como
primer taller fotografía en ese momento
yo no le di la importancia
sino el interés
para
volverme a integrar a la vida educativa
social y laboral
allí aprendí fotografía sensorial
aprendí que falta de ojos tengo oído
tengo el fatto tengo el tacto y un buen
gusto para saborear todo lo exquisito
que existe
así es cómo
aprendí a tomar fotografías
y ustedes se preguntarán
cómo lo hacen
bueno
aprendí a tomar retrato
paisajes objetos
comida por qué no
y así lo hago cuando yo voy a tomar un
retrato
le digo a la persona que me deje tocar
su cabeza sus hombros y que me hable así
ya sé dónde tienen la cabeza y dónde
tomar yo mis dimensiones y tomó la foto
si voy a tomar un paisaje tocó un árbol
el grosor y con eso yo me imagino qué
altura tiene trato de buscar si hay más
árboles
y si solo hay pasto
también ahí yo tomo mi foto
un objeto para un objeto yo toco el
objeto y toco el entorno del lugar para
saber si lo voy a tomar de cerca o de
lejos de picada o contra picada
y claro para la comida
primero la prueba para saber si va a
salir rica la foto
y
entonces después ya tomé mi foto
para mí la fotografía ahora es muy
importante gracias a ella yo estoy
visible
y es un medio de comunicación para todo
el mundo
es por eso que yo me inspiré
en mi psicólogo marco antonio y en azul
para estructurar mi primera foto
esperando que la vean aquí
en ella
ahí está él dicen preguntando que es
azul y yo estoy ahí visible
para comunicarme con todos
para mí
la fotografía ahora es muy importante
porque no saben ustedes cuánta gente
ignora sobre esta discapacidad y la
ignorancia
que a su alrededor hay
no sé cuántos de los que se encuentran
aquí
sepan que si yo hago esto estoy pidiendo
ayuda
machala
la información que no se tiene
también
es es importante decirles que yo
estructuró
azul para comunicarme con los normó
visuales
y para qué
no pasemos desapercibidos
en un mundo donde la marginación y la
discriminación
nos envuelve
cuántas veces a mí me ha tocado
salir de él
del metro
y top y pedir me pueden ayudarte me
pueden ayudar como si estuviera
vendiendo chicles
yo trabajo en una empresa que promueve
la inclusión a grupos vulnerables y aún
así ahí soy invisible
con mis compañeras de trabajo con las
visitas y con algunos usuarios
que prefieren preguntarle
al de seguridad alguna información que
yo les puedo dar verazmente
es difícil
visible ante lo invisible porque entre
nuestro entre los mismos grupos
vulnerables nosotros somos los más
discriminados
cuántas veces me ha tocado a mí en el
banco
hacer un trámite y solo me dicen aquí
está su bache
y yo donde donde no no se ponen a pensar
que con tanta amabilidad y empatía nos
van sacando poco a poco de la oscuridad
para darnos seguridad
y fortaleza y no darnos esa cara de la
discriminación
es por eso
yo les comento
todo lo difícil que es para nosotros
darnos a conocer gracias a la fotografía
john
no quiero pasar desapercibida en este en
este mundo con ustedes
y por medio de la fotografía yo me yo
cada cada cada fotografía para mí tiene
una historia y cada historia tiene una
fotografía
y la y yo cuando yo tomo una foto yo
siento que veo y como en este momento yo
los quiero ver a todos
y quiero conocerles a todos les voy a
tomar una foto
pero para esto no quiero que guarden
silencio quiero que hablen para saber en
dónde están
es efectista
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no quiero que levanten las manos porque
es posible que se la corte y no quiero
ser no quiero ser una bocha amarnos
entonces por favor hagan ruido
[Aplausos]
creo que ya los conozco a todos y ya los
vistos son guapos guapas y muy opuestos
y les agradezco esta atención que
tuvieron para mí espero que se lleven
este mensaje a todas las personas que
conocen hablarles de nuestra
discapacidad
y decirles que es muy difícil
cada día salir y encontrarnos con la
marginación y la discriminación
nos pueden ayudar con empatía y con
amabilidad gracias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]